let's start with robert sala the
jets candidate second interview we
talked about this yesterday chris you
had heard that salah is a serious
candidate to become the coach of the
jets the problem is he completed his
second interview and he left
he's talking to the eagles
and you know we we know what happens
whether it's free agency or coaching you
get the deal done while the guys in the
building or the deal may not get done
matt rule didn't get out of carolina to
go to the giants got the deal done so i
i i
i just wonder what's going on here
because if the jets wanted him they
could have hired him during the second
interview or the interview could have
culminated in the negotiations that
resulted in the contract but for
whatever reason it didn't happen and now
salah continues his tour and the jets
continue to look elsewhere and maybe
they still get together but it sure felt
yesterday like it was moving in that
direction yeah now it doesn't i'm i'm
surprised i thought that you know making
the second trip out there things that i
had heard that yeah it would probably be
you know
all locked up and done and signed signed
sealed and delivered you know by some
point yesterday but i don't know what is
going on there i have no inside info i
know the jets got their eyes on some
other guys other candidates you know one
name i've heard with the jets is arthur
smith you know the tennessee officer
coordinator i heard he's very high up in
the conversations there and then
i've had people lead me to believe that
there's a few one or two other people
who are kind of under the radar that
that they believe are got the eye of the
jets to a degree i don't know who they
are but obviously there's great interest
in robert sala i just don't know is that
the jets going wait we didn't love that
second interview and we want to
interview more are they going wait we
would just like to complete the process
we have a few other people on our list
that we haven't got to yet we just like
to do our due diligence before we start
you know drawing up a contract with you
i don't know either way but of course
they're taking danger if they do like
salah and letting them out the building
and you know you never know what happens
now
or or maybe maybe they came to the
conclusion that we advocated yesterday
and i mentioned it on twitter and it got
a bunch of jets fans triggered the idea
that if you hire salah and he brings in
an offensive coordinator who fixes sam
darnold he's going to lose that guy to
be a head coach somewhere else the jets
are so downtrodden as a fan base they
actually view that as a good development
because it means
that salah at least for a brief period
of time with his offensive coordinator
would have fixed sam darnold even if the
next guy
doesn't
and uh yeah we've seen what happens when
one offensive coordinator leaves there's
no guarantee that the next guy is going
to be as good and you could have a
regression and there there is something
to be said chris
for
consistency
at the offensive coordinator position
year after year after year after year i
am never going to make excuses for kirk
cousins the guy making 33 million a year
needs no excuses to be made for him he
needs to be troubled by nothing anyone
says he's making 33 million a year but
at the same time contrast sean payton
head coach and essentially you know play
caller offensive designer everything
sorry pete carmichael but it's sean
payton with drew brees for all these
years uninterrupted year after year
after year consistency consistency
consistency kirk cousins has been
minnesota in minnesota three years and
he's had three offensive coordinators
yeah because his head coach is a is a
defensive guru that's my point yeah and
maybe the jets didn't like maybe maybe
salla had a plan for a fallback and
here's what we do and you know yeah our
offensive coordinator is going to leave
if things go well with darnold and i
don't know i i hey i
you know i
it's a real people own teams plenty of
people
own teams that that aren't hardcore
football people
and i don't think it takes much to look
at the trends and say
i really don't want us to get on this
cycle of having to hire a new offensive
coordinator every other year i'd much
rather have to hire a defensive
coordinator especially because look at
look at sean payton i talk about this
all the time dennis allen should be in
in this mix why does he never get a
sniff i don't know because we think of
the saints and we think offense even
when their defense is great no you're
right that is that's kind of the
perception there's no doubt about that
and i don't understand why dennis allen
doesn't get a sniff either but
mike as we talked about yesterday this
is a real fear this is a real thing that
i think's on all organizations you know
radar right now about this little issue
you brought it up i really think you're
a big reason of making it known even in
the nfl to go like whoa wait hold on
this is a real thing there's no doubt
about it maybe that is what happened
maybe it is you know now but but these
defensive coaches yeah this is something
they're going to have to deal with here
and answer and really think about how
they're going to attack
this aspect of being a head coach you
know you look at even hey mike rabel he
might lose arthur smith this year where
does that go it's it is it's a real
issue especially with the league and the
rules being so favored to the offense
and the quarterbacks and things like
that
yeah having a good offensive mind is a
huge advantage for your football team
right now so uh i don't know i i don't
know what the right plan of attack is
there for these defensive head coaches i
said yesterday remember i brought in the
you you need to bring one guy as the
offensive coordinator and you need to
tell that offensive coordinator hey who
you got to bring your right-hand man
and i get i'll give you the oc job but i
get first dibs on that guy when you
leave to take your next job you don't
get to take him and being bring him your
oc i get to bring him something like
that is what's gonna have to be done in
these contracts uh for these defensive
head coaches to kind of just calm
gm's or the owners to go okay
yeah i might lose the oc after a year or
two but at least there's a guy after
that to where i don't have to worry
about losing him for a year or two after
that so you buy yourself four or five
years in the process and maybe that's
the best way to go about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports